how's it goin breath money and welcome
to Bradford pear ah on to the Friday
right it's a front it's a Friday
isn't it that I know it I got a new show
for your brother today and it's called
it's just everything I asked you bros on
Twitter on things I can do for Friday
pimp I and I decided why not [ __ ] do
everything so it's called Butte des
everything Paul von de amalah let's get
naked
can I take my shirt back on now Tom this
video ever
it's just everything play some happy
wheels all right brothers play some
happy wheels oops never mind it's just
everything have your dogs doing episode
are you gonna brush get me food or I
will [ __ ] kill you
kymmie cheese ah you're not supposed to
do it yeah sister give me a kiss that is
nasty [ __ ] does everything keep the
camera a sexy stare the whole time
beautiful things taste terrible candy
awful [ __ ] sake
is this a joke it's like someone [ __ ]
put it in plastic and send it away
oh it's attacking me Yolo am i right no
I was really good 12 out of 10
sing for his pips just stands none of
the [ __ ] lyrics I wanna hold it when
my heart baby well be a little fun and
it's fun when you're with me I love it
that's not the right Lady Gaga song just
dance gonna be okay everything have you
girlfriend do a makeover is sick today
so I'm gonna have to do this on my own
bros we're gonna start by applying this
just spray it all over you know I'm
saying just like that's what she said
next up you want to apply the lipstick I
like this neutral color um oh hello
there how you doing there huh why am I
doing this
ha how do I do this I was pretty good
some eye shadow can't forget the mascara
and as a final touch I just like to do
the hair as uh like this so yeah leave a
head go ahead and leave a comment
braiding from 1 to 10 how I did
and remember bros it's not conveying gay
it's called being fabulous this is
depressing beautiful thing give us a
lesson about life I don't know
your pimp I you should have
in that head of yours
don't milk nipples if they aren't soft
beautiful thing that's the big bang into
any is why do I look like Justin Bieber
with this [ __ ] haircut or a lesbian
no offends lesbians but we have the same
haircut let's be honest
let's do it does everything Marc Namie
boots discomfort think I'm falling ask
your fans for this guy's and then have
them and call them
what's up Kalin hey no worry I don't
know switch switch to video then after
you know after you after you
what please please is it as it's real
are you okay okay
what it's a it's just everything do
whatever you like we love it anyways are
you loving this beautiful thing take us
on a tour in your house it's not my
house this is very treacherous science
it's and records not mine here's all the
mmm here's here's all the [ __ ] stuff I
guess so this is where I record you can
see him router and a box and that looks
like condoms but it's thought or games
desk everything get a Yolo tattoo
there we go wait something is missing
have I ever looked more stupid Oh big
subutex everything as a final I would
just like to say thank you bros for
watching my videos just doing that you
are supporting me and I can't tell you
enough how much I appreciate it because
it makes and makes me live my dream
pretty much so for that thank you bros
and we will brofist are you ready for
this I'm not gonna trick you this time
it's this man own woman or man on man on
duck I'm out of breath because I ride
anyway stay out of breath ma come on
activate
you